iris lorenz verwaltet in ihrer berliner
apotheke den alltäglichen mangel lehre
schubladen gelbe platzhalter zettel
statt medikamente für patienten
sie haben ihre medikamente zur zeit
nicht lieferbar
also wir haben jetzt alle wieder nicht
nein wir haben alles versucht wir haben
partner apotheken gefragt wir haben die
großhändler deutschlandweit abgeklappert
ich würde ja auch mit differenz zahlen
wenn das bin ich meinen medikament
bekommen könnte ich verstehe das nicht
warum ist das plötzlich so dass wir
nicht mehr was bekommen was wir brauchen
das ist leider alltag wir können nicht
sagen wann die hersteller wieder
lieferfähig sind heißt nächste woche
nächsten monat nächstes jahr wenn ich
aber ein präparat jeden tag einnehmen
das ist dass es das eine katastrophe
eine medikamentenlieferungen des
großhändlers auch heute ist nicht alles
dabei was benötigt wird vom hertels
mittel über gift präparate
antidepressiva blutdruckmedikamente
antiepileptika antibiotika in der
großhandel für sich bestellt natürlich
auch direkt beim hersteller kriegen auch
keine ware oder auch nur kontingentiert
heißt also unser großhändler bekommt
meine ding fünf packungen die er dann
auf die acht einer berliner apotheken
dann verteilen muss nun geht das
gekloppe los die liste der medikamente
bei denen es derzeit lieferprobleme gibt
es werden von jahr zu jahr mehr 2013
fehlten noch 42 2018 waren es bereits
das frustriert den im alltag so dermaßen
dass ich jedem zweiten patienten sagen
muss neben haben wir nicht geringer
nicht dass doch noch keinen spaß mehr
bin nicht apotheker geworden um den
leuten zu erklären ich habe ihre
tabletten nicht auch krankenhäuser
klagen über medikamentenmangel
offen reden wollen nur wenige aus sorge
die patienten zu verunsichern
professor gerhard ehninger war
medizinischer leiter an der uniklinik
dresden und ging vergangenes jahr in
rente
der onkologe erinnert sich noch gut an
lieferengpässe sogar überlebenswichtigen
transplantationen
wir mussten teilweise behandlungen um
monate verschieben und die gefahr
besteht dass die situation der patienten
schlechter wird und dass das
behandlungsergebnis einfach nicht
erreicht werden kann dass sie
langfristig krankheitsfreie sind dies
sind situationen die vererzte
unerträglich sind und für patienten
verängstigt und und beunruhigend warum
ist das so
der bedarf an arzneien steigt weltweit
doch immer weniger hersteller
produzieren in immer weniger fabriken
fällt einer aus velen
ausweichmöglichkeiten auf andere
standorte
so war das schmerzmittel ibuprofen in
einer bestimmten dosierung monatelang
nicht erhältlichen weil eine fabrik in
texas einen technischen defekt hatte
hinzu kommt die meisten farmer firmen
lassen medikamente in asien herstellen
vor allem in billiglohnländern wie
indien und china
fabriken werden kaum auf
hygienestandards und sicherheit
überprüft so kommt es immer wieder zu
auswählen
experten fordern nun drastische strafen
für pharmafirmen wer nicht liefert hat
das risiko die zulassung zu verlieren
beziehungsweise erhalten
ordnungswidrigkeit zu bezahlen
je länger die lieferung nicht kommt je
mehr bezahlen muss und lebenswichtige
dickeren hoch sanktioniert weil da
spielt man mit dem leben von menschen
denn nicht alle medikamente können
problemlos ausgetauscht werden
wir haben ja nicht umsonst
unterschiedliche arzneiformen ich habe
mehrere patienten die haben
schluckstörungen die können nur lösliche
präparate oder tropfen einnehmen die
kriegen keine kapsel runter die
lieferprobleme sorgen kritiker hätten
noch einen anderen grund die konzerne
verkauften medikamente ins ausland wenn
es dort profitabler sein
die pharmafirmen gehen einfach so hin
und sagen wo kriege ich jetzt für das
medikament also am meisten
und wenn das medikament wenig lief dabei
ist ich sage mal es gibt engpässe und
dann ist es umso lukrativer damit erhöhe
ich quasi den gewinn als in dem moment
wo ich sozusagen den lieferengpass also
zumindest toleriert oder ihn sogar
selbst verursachen kann ich die preise
in die höhe treiben werde ich der
einzige anbieter bin dass sein
unethisches geschäft der bundesverband
der pharmazeutischen industrie hingegen
gibt der politik die schuld zitat
lieferengpässe sind auch politisch
hausgemacht vor allem durch
rabattverträge und den damit erzeugten
preisdruck
die krankenkassen dürfen nämlich
rabattverträge mit den herstellern
aushandeln
so werden medikamente in großen mengen
günstiger damit konzentriere sich der
markt auf wenige anbieter argumentieren
die hersteller das risiko von
lieferengpässen steigern und die
krankenkassen halten dagegen
dorthin ist nach wie vor ein hoch
attraktiver markt für die
pharmaindustrie die rabattverträge der
krankenkassen müssen sein um die
arzneimittelausgaben in den griff zu
behalten sie jetzt für die
lieferengpässe der hersteller
verantwortlich zu machen
das würde ihre bedeutung garantiert
überschätzen denn der deutsche markt
macht lediglich vier prozent an der
gesamten weltproduktion aus
während sich die akteure über die
ursachen streiten leiden die patienten
die 14 jährige kim ist an epilepsie
erkrankt seit 2010 nimmt sie gegen
krampfanfälle das medikament frisium das
war plötzlich wochenlang nicht mehr
verfügbar
alternativen gibt es nicht dann haben
wir über facebook aufrufe gemacht bei
mir war es dann so dass eine bekannte
100 kilometer entfernt in die apotheke
gegen die apotheke sagt die hatten wir
haben drei packungen liegen die wollen
nicht abgeholt ich bin aber ganz schnell
zum arzt die sage ich brauche schnell
auf rezept und hab da hingeschickt und
habe so meine medikamente bekommen
derzeit ist das medikament wieder
lieferbar niemand weiß wie lange
silke tomaszewski sagt ihre tochter kind
könne ohne frisium nicht leben da
entsteht nun mal dann ein eiskalter ein
zug wenn diese medikamente plötzlich
nicht mehr da sind und diesen zug möchte
glaube ich keiner erleben weil ich
vermute mal das würde uns auf die
intensivstation bringen und dass die
kinder werden dann teilweise ins
künstliche koma gelegt weil die aus dem
krampfen und sie kriegen einzugs anfälle
und hören einfach nicht mehr auf zu
kämpfen
und das kann ja bis zum tod gehen jetzt
sollen vermehrt in europa produziert
werden fordern gesundheitspolitiker der
großen koalition firmen vorschreiben wo
sie produzieren müssen
das ist in einer globalisierten
wirtschaft kaum machbar
professor weniger sagt das
gesundheitsministerium hat das problem
viel zu lange unterschätzt
jahr für jahr werden mehr fälle gemeldet
und deshalb würde ich diese forderung an
das bmg an das bundesministerium für
gesundheit und dort an die spitze des
hauses nämlich ein bundesminister
adressieren kümmern sie sich darum weil
das essen umgang mit menschen wie es
nicht sein sollte und gefährdet menschen
bis hin zum tod
gesundheitsminister jens spahn will uns
kein interview geben teilt aber mit er
wolle das thema europaweit lösen
konkrete pläne wie gibt es aber noch
nicht
apothekerin ins lorenz macht das lange
warten auf eine lösung fassungslos ich
weiß auch nicht ob todesfälle brauchen
bevor irgendwer mal reagiert und sagt
hier müssen muss gehandelt werden dem
brauchen eine stabile versorgungslage in
deutschland 2009 10 ist es nicht möglich
unsere patienten adäquat zu versorgen
das ist das ist traurig
[Musik]